[Musique]
à
une leçon de ses soldats
soit en est votre projet
salut les copains bon ben j'ai vu sur
tik tok un gars faire un max défi max
hurler sur les biceps pencher pas tenir
ma séance me fait chier je vais tester
[Musique]
kg
60 kg
70 kg
[Musique]
karaté albert thurien tous pétain
voilà peut-être la donne c'est pas
brillant
e shariat
alors allez tu sais quoi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'en reviens tu vas passer nous voici
venu voir
[Musique]
coco oui ça vu que c'était un aventurier
hotmail qui s'en servaient de chez lui
mais enfin nico je ne crois pas ban en
toile de jute aventuriers bajaur les
cheveux qui pousse toi ok
on merde claude savard départ alors là
je suis
au nom raconte moi et m'a dit que tu
avais la coupe un combat oui j'avais la
maison